what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting
to an old man's advice i saw this video
on youtube it just looked interesting so
i decided i'm going to react to it
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel
and while you're at it ring the
notification bell because that way
you're going to be notified
of my daily videos okay let's get this
started
good morning whoops it's raining
hold on a minute there
i thought i'd talk to you a little bit
this morning about
uh oh by the way this is a new computer
and
it does all kinds of things so i have to
be careful
i'm not the sharpest tack in the box
when it comes to
this new equipment you're talking to a
guy or a guy speaking to you now
that started driving a model a car i
remember the first jet airplane and many
first things the iceman delivering ice
to an
ice box taking it off of a mule-drawn
wagon
so but i'd like to speak to you a little
bit this morning about uh
young people in particular about
accomplishing things
when i was young as you know
i had a difficult childhood but
there's no excuse for people not being
able to do
what they want to do you can do anything
that you want to do for example
as i've told you before i lived in the
back of an old car i taught myself to
read and write
so if you're young don't give up
don't say the world is just against me
that's not true
i taught myself to read and write i've
had five books published
wow that's so cool i went to college
uh got a little bit of college and i
actually
i mean i think sometimes like it's not
going to work out the way you think
um for example like not everybody can go
to the nba but i think if you work
towards something
even if you don't accomplish like your
first choice of goal
you'll get something that maybe you
weren't expecting if that makes sense
but you know i'm 24. so this is just my
two cents listen to him
i've studied scripture for many many
years
i've raised five children wow i've
buried a mother father sister brother
wife and daughter
so a person can accomplish
anything that they want one time
to prove to myself that i was not an
ignorant person i bought a blackboard
and i purchased a correspondence course
for computer programming and i completed
it with the blackboard
so
forge ahead
don't stop never stop learning
always reach out to better yourself
because when you do that
things expand you understand more
you're happier you're healthier
this old saying that
if you don't use it you lose it
is absolutely true if you don't use that
brain
that god put in your head
one of these days you'll be sitting
on a front porch somewhere
and you won't hardly know what's going
on
i actually agree with
if you don't use it you lose it a lot i
mean i don't know too much about like
brain deterioration or anything but when
i look back at like
the people that worked hard versus the
people that were just talented
like if the people that were talented
didn't work hard like the people that
worked hard
always won always always always always
beat them out in the long run not in the
short one
run all the time but in the long run
they did
when i think i like sports
like for me i'm only 24 so
so don't don't give up
if times are hard good things nor bad
things
last forever but
most generally we are in control
of our own destiny
and when i say that i mean
this
if you're not getting ahead
you need to do something to allow
yourself to get ahead
for example excuse me
for an example if if you want a good job
if you want a secure future you have to
have something
to offer a prospective employer
now i'm not saying you need a phd or a
master's degree
but you do don't go to college it's
waste of money you have to have
something to offer
there's going to be a time in this
country
but people that know how to work with
their hands
plumbers electricians
carpenters cement layers machine
operators
mechanics people that know how to work
with their hands
are going to be in great demand
yeah i bet that's that's coming soon i
used to work at a plumbing like
tech company and it was actually insane
to me what the plumbers make it was way
more than i thought
yes it's true you have to have education
and training to
be an engineer or a doctor or a lawyer
but i'll tell you the truth i spent 60
years working
i was successful i started a couple of
businesses i'm not a wealthy man but i'm
a guy that came from living in the back
of an old car
to having a nice retirement and to be
able to talk to you
on this thing so i'm going to close but
i i just wanted to to share that with
you this morning
young people i love you i do i love
young people my grandmother always said
you know when a baby smiles the angels
sing and that's true
i believe but young people you're the
backbone
of this country you're the backbone of
the world i don't care if you're in asia
africa korea japan i don't care where
you are
the united states you are the leaders
the future leaders
of this world so reach out be yourselves
don't be afraid to to to go after what
you need
so i love you have a great day and i'll
see you tomorrow
um i actually heard this guy just passed
away but he's so
cute um i really like how encouraging he
is you always hear about how the next
generation is the one that's like the
worst gonna mess up america so it's
really cool to see someone that's
actually
you know like encouraging and like
saying that you know things aren't all
doomed they're actually good things
coming
and you can be the change that you want
to see in the world so that was a cool
change of pace and when i normally
watch on this channel so let me know if
you like these type of reactions
in the comments do not forget to
subscribe to the channel
trying to get to 20 000 subscribers each
and every one of you helps
and don't forget to ring that
notification bell i'll talk to you guys
next time